hi I'm pulling on Martinez and I'm a
screenwriter because I have my first
draft what feels so good to say that
but storytelling actually started a long
time ago for me I remember being really
young and sitting around with my big
Mexican family my mom has 215 siblings
and they would sit around and tell
stories about when they were younger and
when they worked as farmworkers in the
50s 60s and 70s and I remember being
drawn in just imagining what their lives
might have been like and it got me
writing and eventually I went to UCSD
and I got a BA in visual arts and film
and then I went on to get an MFA at the
School of Cinematic Arts at USC in film
production where I focus on writing
directing and producing but now I am
really honed in to writing because I
finally found the one the story that I'm
turning into my first feature screenplay
and I am well into my second draft which
is so exciting I've had to find sort of
a unique way to get the screenplay done
I've been working on it for over a year
and a half and I have a full-time job in
LA so it's really hard to write during
the week I work at this amazing
production company in development so I
figured out that I could sneak away and
retreat to my mom's house outside of the
city and that really has helped get this
screenplay done so here I am in my
favorite spot which is my mom's backyard
and with my best friends my headphones
my laptop my notepad and my iPad writing
can often be a pretty isolating process
that when you have the right tools and
the motivation it gets done so that you
know
storytelling for me has always been why
I decided I wanted to write screenplays
you know I'm here at this house and it
always reminds me of my mom's own story
you know she didn't come from a lot and
and she worked so hard to make a better
life for herself and now she's this
beautiful home near the ocean where I
get to come and and work on this story
that all
so so motivated to me it's based on real
events and about a real woman it was a
motorcycle trailblazer who taught
herself how to ride a motorcycle when
everyone said girls didn't ride back in
the 1920s and eventually took a solo
motorcycle road trip into the south by
herself
what so you know writing the story has
been great especially because my
character motivates me to get up early
to stay up late and and to really you
know follow through and get this done I
write stories in order to motivate other
people as well I believe storytelling
has the potential to elevate the human
spirit and to open hearts minds and
imaginations and as corny as that may
sound I really believe that and that
really pushes me to write and that's
what I I want to do for the rest of my
life and every morning I get excited
thinking about my characters and scenes
that I'm gonna add and you know like any
other screenwriter my dream is to get
this out so people can see it and and
again to keep writing so you know as
soon as I get this screenplay done I
have a book adaptation lined up it's a
story about another incredible woman
this time it takes place in Germany and
sent East Berlin and it's just you know
I feel privileged and honored to be able
to you know bring these people in these
stories to life and I do I feel I feel
honored to be a part of this process and
to be able to be doing this for a living
and I just
I'm so excited to bring the story to to
everyone and I hope it's sittin later so
I just wanted to say again thank you for
this opportunity and for supporting
writing and writers out there I hope you
have a really fun time watching all
these videos and that you find what
you're looking for so thanks again for
the opportunity and Cheers
to multiple drafts and to writing